Adams finds gallo on the mismatch  against the lawn right that was easy and  that's the difference between him and a  lotta Foreman how he's added that aspect  to his game in the NBA  [Applause]  played with in Sacramento I'm sure right  well you did Chris you can play with it  and that's what Steven Adams does best  get offensive rebounds had it knocked  away Gallinari with a mismatch against  Iran right no and the slam at the rim  III do I think that's that's part of the  motivation that guys used to work in  their favor  tough shot what Rick Carlisle is it  might be a fluid starting line on  Gallinari counters at the other end and  that's a toilet offensive player what's  with the big step it out and doing their  thing today Paulo we belong to and then  alizée Johnson lost it spinning in delay  there's heal buddy hield a three-point  shooter pulls up this is transition he  pulls